[Música]
johnny pacheco el director de la
orquesta para fijarlo el pianista
virtuoso
roberto roena el gran bailarín un
dominicano un neoyorquino y un
puertorriqueño que representan la
esencia más pura de la salsa johnny
pacheco cuando en la gran manzana el
sello fania records en 1964 y es
considerado como el padre de la salsa un
sonido que pacheco acuñó inspirado en
los ritmos afroantillanos y caribeños
que escuchaba en su infancia en
república dominicana
en 1968 crea la agrupación fania
all-stars reuniendo a las estrellas más
grandes de la discográfica larry harlow
fue el segundo artista que contrató la
hazaña con un estilo revolucionario que
combinaba trompetas y trombones lo
llamaban el judío maravilloso
a roberto roena además de la percusión
que identificaban sus pasos bailarín
desde niño fue uno de los fundadores del
gran combo de puerto rico en 1962 en
1969 da vida a su propia orquesta
roberto roena y su apollo sound el
sonido del latín jazz
no
terry cada cual
entre los 3 cientos de álbumes
producidos y también centenares de
canciones además tocaban varios
instrumentos
hicieron parte de una elite que también
integraban celia cruz cheo feliciano
héctor la voz rey barreto entre otros
grandes nombres
[Música]